واياكم مشاهدينا الكرام هذا الفيديو
المتداول
لهجوم على سجن كوبر هذا السجن الذي يتواجد
فيه الرئيس السوداني المعزول عمر
البشير وكانت طبعا قد شهدت
السودان الخرطوم تحديدا هجوما اخر لاطلاق
سراح بعض من كانوا موجودين في سجن
الهدى كما طبعا انتشرت الاخبار والانباء
ايضا كذلك وحتى الفيديوهات على مواقع
التواصل الاجتماعي هذا مقطع متداول ايضا
اخر لهجوم على سجن كوبر بالخرطوم هناك
انباء عن هروب سجناء من داخل هذا السجن
سجن كوبر وكما ذكرنا وهو السجن الذي
يتواجد به الرئيس المعزول عمر البشير
وكذلك ايضا بعض السياسيين وفول النظام
السوداني السابق الموجودين داخل هذا
السجن سجن كوبر اذا هذا مقطع متداول لهجوم
على سجن كوبر كما ذكرنا قبل قليل لمتابعه
المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج والقصص
الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات